well now we're going to the bahamas to
meet a remarkable group of dolphins that
i've been working with in the wild for
the last 28 years
now i'm interested in dolphins because
of their large brains and what they
might be doing with all that brain power
in the wild
and we know they use some of that brain
power for just living complicated lives
but what do we really know about dolphin
intelligence
well we know a few things we know that
their brain to body ratio which is a
physical measure of intelligence is
second only to humans
cognitively they can understand
artificially created languages
and they pass self-awareness tests in
mirrors and in some parts of the world
they use tools like sponges to hunt fish
but there's one big question left
do they have a language and if so what
are they talking about
so decades ago
not years ago
i set out to find a place in the world
where i could observe dolphins
underwater and to try to crack the code
of their communication system
now in most parts of the world the water
is pretty murky so it's very hard to
observe animals underwater but i found a
community of dolphins that live in these
beautiful clear shallow sandbanks of the
bahamas which are just east of florida
and they spend their day time resting
and socializing in the safety of the
shallows but at night they go off the
edge
and hunt in deep water
now it's not a bad place to be a
researcher either
so we go out for about five months every
summer in a 20 meter catamaran and we
live sleep
and work at sea for weeks at a time
my main tool is an underwater video with
a hydrophone which is underwater
microphone and this is so i can
correlate sound and behavior and most of
our work's pretty non-invasive we try to
follow dolphin etiquette while we're in
the water since we're actually observing
them physically in the water
now atlantic spotted dolphins are a
really nice species to work with for a
couple reasons they're born without
spots and they get spots with age and
they go through pretty distinct
developmental phases so that's fun to
track their behavior and by about the
age of 15 they're fully spotted black
and white now the mother you see here is
mugsy she's 35 years old in this shot
but dolphins can actually live into
their early 50s
and like all the dolphins in our
community we photographed a mugsy and
tracked her little spots and nicks and
her dorsal fin and also the unique spot
patterns as she matured over time now
young dolphins learn a lot as they're
growing up and they use their teenage
years to practice social skills and at
about the age of nine the females become
sexually mature so they can get pregnant
and the males mature quite a bit later
at around 15 years of age
and dolphins are very promiscuous and so
we have to determine who the fathers are
so we do paternity tests by collecting
fecal material out of the water and
extracting dna
so what that means is after 28 years we
are tracking three generations including
grandmothers and grandfathers
now dolphins are natural acousticians
they make sounds 10 times as high and
here sounds 10 times as high as we do
but they have other communication
signals they use they have good vision
so they use body postures to communicate
they have taste not smell
and they have touch
and sound can actually be felt in the
water because the acoustic impedance of
tissue and water is about the same so
dolphins can buzz and tickle each other
at a distance
and now we do know some things about how
sounds are used with certain behaviors
now the signature whistle is a whistle
that's specific to an individual dolphin
and it's like a name
and uh this is the best studied sound
because it's easy to measure really and
you'd find this whistle when mothers and
calves are reuniting for example
another well-studied sound are
echolocation clicks this is the dolphin
sonar
and they use these clicks to hunt and
feed
but they can also tightly pack these
clicks together into buzzes and use them
socially for example males will
stimulate a female during a courtship
chase
you know i've been buzzed in the water
don't tell anyone it's a secret
and you can really feel the sound that
was my point with that
[Laughter]
so dolphins are also political animals
and
so they have to resolve conflicts
and they use these burst pulse sounds as
well as their head-to-head behaviors
when they're fighting
and these are very unstudied sounds
because they're hard to measure
now this is some video of a typical
dolphin site
so you're going to see two groups
you're going to see the head-to-head
posturing
some open mouth
lots of squawking
there's a bubble
and basically one of these groups will
kind of back off and everything will
resolve fine and it doesn't really
escalate into violence
too much
now in the bahamas we also have resonant
bottlenose that interact socially with
the spotted dolphins for example they
babysit each other's calves the males
have dominance displays they use when
they're chasing each other's females
and the two species actually form
temporary alliances when they're chasing
sharks away
and one of the mechanisms they use to
communicate their coordination is
synchrony they synchronize their sounds
and their body postures
to look bigger and sound stronger
now these are bottlenose dolphins
and you'll see them starting to
synchronize their behavior and their
sound
you see they're synchronizing with their
partner as well as the other
dyad wish i was that coordinated
now it's important to remember that
you're only hearing the human audible
parts of dolphin sounds and dolphins
make ultrasonic sounds and we use
special equipment in the water to
collect these sounds
now researchers have actually measured
whistle complexity using information
theory and whistles rate very high
relative to even human languages
but burst pulse sounds is a bit of a
mystery
now
these are three spectrograms two are
human words and one is a dolphin
vocalizing so just take a guess in your
mind which one is the dolphin
now it turns out burst pulse sounds
actually look a bit like human phonemes
now one way to crack the code is to
interpret these signals and figure out
what they mean but it's a difficult job
and we actually don't have a rosetta
stone yet but a second way to crack the
code is to develop some technology and
interface to do two-way communication
and that's what we've been trying to do
in the bahamas and in real time
now scientists have used keyboard
interfaces
to try to bridge the gap with species
including chimpanzees and dolphins this
underwater keyboard in orlando florida
at the epcot center was actually the
most sophisticated ever two-way
interface designed for humans and
dolphins to work together under the
water and exchange information
so we wanted to develop an interface
like this in the bahamas but in a more
natural setting
and one of the reasons we thought we
could do this is because the dolphins
were starting to show us
a lot of mutual curiosity they were
spontaneously mimicking our
vocalizations and our postures
and they were also inviting us into
dolphin games
now dolphins are social mammals so they
love to play
and one of their favorite games is to
drag seaweed or sargassum in this case
around
and they're very adept they like to drag
it on drop it from appendage to
appendage
now in this footage of the adult is
carol she's 25 years old here and this
is her newborn cobalt and he's just
learning how to play this game
she's kind of teasing him and taunting
him
he really wants that sardansson
now when dolphins solicit humans for
this game
they'll often sink vertically in the
water
and they'll have a little sargassum on
their flipper and they'll sort of nudge
it and drop it sometimes on the bottom
and let us go get it and we'll have a
little seaweed away
but when we don't dive down and get it
they'll bring it to the surface
and they'll sort of wave it in front of
us on their tail and drop it for us like
they do their calves and then we'll pick
it up and have a game
and so we started thinking well wouldn't
it be neat
to build some technology that would
allow the dolphins to request these
things in real time their favorite toys
so the original vision was to have a
keyboard hanging from the boat attached
to a computer and the divers and
dolphins would activate the keys on the
keypad and happily exchange information
and request toys from each other but we
quickly found out the dolphins simply
were not going to hang around the boat
using a keyboard
they've got better things to do in the
wild they might do in captivity but in
the wild so we built a portable keyboard
that would push through the water and we
labeled four objects they'd like to play
with the scarf rope sargassum and also
had a bow ride which is a fun activity
for a dolphin
and that's the scarf whistle which is
also associated with the visual symbols
and these are artificially created
whistles they're outside the dolphin's
normal repertoire
but they're easily mimicked by the
dolphins
and i spent four years with my
colleagues adam pack and fabian del four
working out in the field with this
keyboard using it with each other to do
requests for toys while the dolphins
were watching and the dolphins could get
in on the game they could point at the
visual object or they could mimic the
whistle
now this is video
of a session
the diver here has a rope toy
and i'm on the keyboard on the left and
i'm about to
i've just played the rope key and that's
the request for the toy from the human
so i've got the rope i'm diving down
and i'm basically trying to get the
dolphins attention because we're kind of
like little kids you have to keep their
attention
i'm going to drop the rope see if they
come over
and here they come
then i'm going to pick up the rope and
drag it around as a toy
now i'm at the keyboard on the left and
this is actually the first time we tried
this i'm going to try to request
this toy the rope toy from the dolphins
using the rope sound see if they
might actually understand what that
means
that's the rope whistle
up come the dolphins and drop off the
road
[Music]
well
so this is only once you know we don't
know for sure if they really understand
the function of the whistles okay so
here's a second second toy in the water
this is a scarf toy and i'm trying to
lead the dolphin over to the keyboard
to show her the
visual and the acoustic signal
now this dolphin we call her the scarf
thief
because over the years she's absconded
with about 12 scarves
in fact we think she has a boutique
somewhere in the bahamas
so i'm reaching over she's got the scarf
on her right side
and we try to not touch the animals too
much we really don't want to
overhabituate them and i'm trying to
lead her back to the keyboard
and the diver there is going to activate
the scarf sound to request the scarves
so i try to give her the scarf
whoop i almost lost it
but this this is the moment where
everything becomes possible the dolphins
at the keyboard you've got full
attention
and this sometimes went on for hours and
i wanted to share this video with you
not to show you any big breakthroughs
because they haven't happened yet but to
show you the level of intention and
focus that these dolphins have and
interest in the system and because of
this we really decided we needed some
more sophisticated technology so we
joined forces with georgia tech with sad
starters uh wearable computing group to
build us an underwater wearable computer
that we're calling chat
now instead of pushing a keyboard
through the water the diver's wearing
the complete system and it's acoustic
only
so basically the diver activates the
sounds on a keypad on the forearm the
sounds go out through an underwater
speaker if dolphin mimics a whistle or a
human plays a whistle the sounds come in
and are localized by two hydrophones
the computer can localize who who
requested the toy if there's a word
match
and the real power of the system is in
the real time sound recognition so we
can respond to the dolphins quickly and
accurately
and we're at prototype stage but this is
how we hope it will play out so diver a
and diver b both have a wearable
computer and the dolphin hears the
whistle as a whistle the diver hears the
whistle as a whistle in the water but
also as a word through bone conduction
so diveree plays a scarf whistle or
diver b plays a sargassum whistle to
request a toy from whoever has it what
we hope will happen
is that the dolphin mimics the whistle
and if diver a has the sargassum if
that's the sound that was
played and requested
then the diver will give the sargassum
to the requesting dolphin and they'll
swim away happily in the sunset thing
sargasso for forever
now how far can this kind of
communication go
well chat is designed specifically to
empower the dolphins to request things
from us
it's designed to really be two-way
now will they learn to mimic the
whistles functionally we hope so when we
think so
but as we decode their natural sounds
we're also planning to put those back
into the computerized system for example
right now we can put their own signature
whistles in the computer and request to
interact with a specific dolphin
likewise we can create
our own whistles our own whistle names
and let the dolphins request specific
divers to interact with
now it may be that all our mobile
technology will actually be the same
technology that helps us
communicate with another species down
the road
in the case of a dolphin you know it's
it's a species that
they're probably close to our
intelligence in many ways and we might
not be able to admit that right now but
they live in a quite a different
environment and you still have to bridge
the gap with the sensory systems
now imagine what it would be like to
really understand the mind of another
intelligent species on the planet
thank you
you